hey it's dr berg in this video we're
going to talk about one of the most
common vitamin deficiencies low b1 okay
this is a tree with branches these are
symptoms these are roots
i know it doesn't look like a tree but
that's what it is okay first symptom is
restless legs restless leg syndrome
that's a b1 deficiency
it's a buildup of lactic acid lactic
acid builds up from a natural process of
of carbohydrate metabolism or sugar
metabolism in your body so if you're
eating too much sugar or
breads and pasta and cereal and crackers
all that stuff
and it can't clear it
you'll end up with restless leg it's
like a lot of nervous energy in your
legs and other parts of your body and if
you work out and you feel sore a little
too long you could take some b1 and get
rid of that soreness really fast because
this is the remedy for restless legs
if you look up
low vitamin b1
a classic vitamin deficiency like really
severe they call that berry berry
beriberi affects the heart and that's
why the pulse rate starts going higher
and higher and higher with a b1
deficiency you also end up backing up
with fluid into your legs edema from a
low vitamin b1 as well because the heart
is weak
another deficiency because this controls
the nerve especially the myelin the the
outside of the sheath of the nerve if
that thing is gone if you don't have
enough b1 you won't be able to build up
the my the surrounding protective
coating around the nerves and then you
get tingling and numbness in your
fingers hands and feet and toes and
that's why diabetics for example
end up with peripheral neuropathy that's
the tingling in the feet and the hands
because they have very deficient in b1
in fact
diabetics
need about 15 times more b1
than a normal person they're very very
low in b1 and when you actually give
them b1 in a natural form it actually
helps lower their insulin so it's really
good for diabetics but that's why they
get those symptoms because they run out
of the b1 and that's the remedy okay
nightmares is a classic symptom for low
b1 as well
air hunger at night is a symptom of low
b1 coughing at night is another symptom
of low b1
calf tenderness press in your calf this
tender could be low b1 and nystigmus now
what is nystigmus if i were to look at
you right now and turn my head but yet
maintain
my eyeballs my eyeballs are going in the
opposite direction as i'm turning my
head and that's coordinated with
something in your inner ear
that has these little nerve endings
these little hairs in a fluid in the
inner ear it's like a little gyroscope
back there and that nerve that's
connected to the ear is disrupted with a
low b1 because low b1 affects the
nervous system
and an astigmus is that that
coordination isn't occurring so you'll
have this dancing eye so you'll see the
eye just dancing like that that's
nostigmus but that's coming from a low
b1
and then the last symptom of oh low b1
is the nervous energy like you have this
you come home at night and you're like
stressed out and you can't relax
and you just feel this up
or doom and gloom okay you have this
weight over your shoulders
take some b1 and watch how fast that
goes away simply because now the cause
of low b1 would be excessive stress when
you use a lot of mental energy in
physical energy you deplete your b1
reserve so
alcohol
will also deplete b1
liver damage will deplete b1 and then of
course the classic too much sugar
or
just sugar and i mean not too much just
you shouldn't eat any sugar because
that's going to deplete b1 and then
refine carbohydrates and that would be
the breads pasta cereal crackers
biscuits
i don't recommend taking a synthetic b1
unless you're doing some type of
detoxification cleanse and it's a
short-term thing
you'd be much better off
taking nutritional yeast
that's a more natural form not brewer's
yeast not baker's yeast but nutritional
yeast it's at the health food store it
comes in a container take a teaspoonful
every single day that's what i do put it
in some plain yogurt
or
kefir
okay that's kind of a sour yogurt and i
usually take that in the morning and
you'll get all your bees and you'll
actually help a lot of these symptoms so
go ahead and apply this and i will see
you in the next video